[Musica]
tutti cercano la felicità se domandi
agli uomini se vogliono diventare
militari è probabile che uno ti dica di
sì e l'altro no ma se domandi loro se
vogliono essere felici entrambi ti
risponderanno subito senza ombra di
dubbio di sì anzi il motivo per cui uno
vuole fare il militare e l'altro no è
soltanto la felicità
questo lo diceva sant'agostino 1600 anni
fa ma possiamo ribadirlo anche oggi
anche noi che siamo qui io che parlo su
questo palco
chi ha organizzato questo the text voi
che siete qui a questo evento che ci sta
guardando da casa lo stiamo facendo
perché crediamo che in qualche modo
tutto ciò centri con la nostra felicità
ma anche uscire con gli amici
fare sport mettere al mondo un figlio
perché lo facciamo perché investiamo
energie in questa attività
il motivo è sempre la felicità
ma che cos'è la felicità se dovessimo
definirla riusciremo a dare una risposta
è una domanda difficile e anche
pericolosa perché il rischio è quello di
dover ammettere di non saperlo però
essenziale farlo perché almeno ci
costringe a mettere a fuoco qual è il
bersaglio della nostra vita perché
sarebbe un peccato dannarsi l'anima per
essere felici e alla fine rendersi conto
che tutti i tentativi che abbiamo fatto
sono andati a vuoto semplicemente perché
avevamo ammirato il bersaglio sbagliato
la parola peccato in greco significa
esattamente questo mancare il bersaglio
la maggior parte dei peccati che
commettiamo sono in realtà dei tentativi
di essere felici andati a male e il
peccato più grande è quello di non
essere felici e siamo siamo felici forse
è perché non sappiamo chi cos'è la
felicità o forse perché l'abbiamo
confusa con altro ad esempio potremo
averla confusa con la ricerca del
piacere
allora grazie a dio la vita è bella
perché possiamo godere di molti piaceri
però
mangiare bene e fare sport fare sesso
non possono esaurire la ricerca della
felicità d'altra parte sono piaceri per
cui di loro natura sono momentanei
quando finiscono rischiano pure di
lasciarci magari un vuoto in fondo al
cuore oppure potremmo avere conclusa la
felicità con il benessere alimentazione
e salute cura del corpo meditazione
soldi certo tutto questo concorre alla
felicità
ma non è tutto conosco ammalati che sono
felici nonostante la loro malattia e
persone benestanti che sono tristi
nonostante una forma fisica impeccabile
infine potremmo aver confuso alla
felicità con la realizzazione
individuale
allora è giusto anzi doveroso impegnarsi
per diventare quello che vogliamo e per
dar forma ai nostri desideri
però non possiamo far dipendere la
nostra felicità dal raggiungimento delle
nostre ambizioni
ci sono delle persone magari realizzati
dal punto di vista professionale
economico che ogni tanto i giornali ci
fanno capire che anche maniera
drammatica non erano per niente felici
la felicità non è solo il piacere non è
solo il benessere non è solo la
realizzazione individuale quindi che
cos'è
prima di rispondere a questa domanda
però dobbiamo porci è un'altra forse più
pericolosa o per lo meno io ho dovuto
fare così avevo 17 anni era nel pieno
della mia adolescenza
avevo il cuore è piena di sogni e la
testa piena di dubbi erano poco è
arrivato un prete nuova della mia
parrocchia uno molto giovane che
peraltro mi stava pure neanche troppo
simpatico
una sera dopo un incontro in oratorio si
offre di accompagnarmi a casa perché era
un po ci conosciamo poi ci salutiamo
faccio per uscire dalla macchina ma mi
ferma aspetta
mi guarda dritto negli occhi serissimo
sei felice pietrificato non me n'ero mai
chiesto e nessuno mi aveva mai posto
questa domanda in questa maniera non
sapevo cosa rispondere
d'altra parte mi rendevo conto che lui
interessava veramente la mia risposta e
aveva lo sguardo di chi sapeva davvero
che cosa fosse la felicità ho provato a
balbettare qualcosa giusto per evitare
di far brutta figura ma ci ha pensato
lui a salvarmi dall'imbarazzo
non mi deve rispondere subito mi ha
detto questa è una domanda importante
anzi forse la più importante della vita
pensaci attentamente ed è così che sono
andato in crisi quella sera su quella
macchina io mi sono reso conto di non
sapere se fossi felice o meno non me
l'hanno mai chiesto direttamente ero
ragazzo contento
tanti i piaceri è una romena scuola
facevo sport con gli amici un certo
grado di benessere però in fondo al
cuore
non ero felice perché allora ho provato
a guardarmi intorno ad osservare la vita
degli altri per capire come poter essere
felice
anzi non ho mai smesso di farlo perché
questa faccenda per me è davvero troppo
importante
ma quello che ho trovato a volte anche
oggi mi lascia un po con l'amaro in
bocca
vedo tantissimi ragazzi che si divertono
come dei martiri al sabato notte e poi
si trascinano a scuola svogliati per il
resto della settimana
vedo metropolitane affollate di uomini e
donne in carriera che trovano un sacco
di tempo per lavorare ma neanche un
istante per sorridere a un povero vedo
che non ci accontentiamo mai di niente
perché non appena esce un nuovo modello
di scarpa o il nuovo modello di telefono
subito ci precipitiamo per comprarlo
e non dite che non è vero perché lo
faccio anch'io un bisogno smodato di
piaceri e tanto benessere una rincorsa
sfrenata alla realizzazione individuale
e questa la felicità che cerchiamo il
numero di ragazzi che consumano droghe
regolarmente e in forte aumento il tasso
di suicidio fra gli adolescenti sta
impennando episodi di autolesionismo
attacchi di panico nelle scuole sono
all'ordine del giorno
pensate la depressione fino a qualche
decennio fa era una malattia che
riguardava la fascia adulta della
popolazione adesso invece a doversi
rivolgere agli psicologi per un sostegno
specifico oppure anche i farmaci sono
persino i ragazzi delle medie
forse insomma cosa che non va forse
tutto il sistema non va
oggi la cultura contemporanea non è più
basata sulla felicità sulla ricerca del
senso sull'essere ma sulla produttività
sulla ricerca dell'utile sul fare in
altre parole è l'economia
il cuore del mondo non l'uomo una
persona felice non produce utile sono
gli infelici che fanno girare l'economia
e muovono il capitalismo perché chi
compra tanto compra partire dalla
propria infelicità che felice in fondo
non ha bisogno di niente per questo il
mondo deve alimentare l'infelicità
perché questa che fa girare l'economia
ci hanno fatto credere che saremo felici
quando avremo quello che ora ci manca
quando raggiungeremo quella data forma
fisica quando saremo la persona che
adesso non siamo
ed eccoci qua sazi e disperati con la
pancia piena
eppure sempre insoddisfatti come quel
giovane che tanto tempo fa era andato al
corsara gesù per chiedergli come fare
per essere finalmente felice ma hai
tutto quello che ti serve per esserlo
gli rispose no non basta gli disse il
giovane gesù capi che voleva fare sul
serio lo guardò fisso negli occhi e gli
disse il segreto della felicità è questo
vendi tutti i tuoi beni dagli ai poveri
e seguimi
sbam una sberla inaspettata tutti i miei
beni non ce la faccio e quel giovane
quel giorno se ne andò triste perché
possedeva troppo e non riusciva a dare
niente agli altri
ecco perché non riusciva ad essere
felice perché vivevo solo per me stesso
e non riuscivo a mettere la mia vita a
disposizione degli altri la mia crisi di
infelicità era in realtà una crisi di
infecondità esistenziale la parola
felice alla stessa radice di secondo
felix il latino indicava all albero da
frutto
arbor felix per il contadino era
l'albero che portava frutta da mangiare
in tavola oppure da usare per nove
seminagioni l'albero felice era l'albero
fertile che nutre e generalità la
persona felice è una persona feconda che
arricchisce la vita degli altri con la
propria e genera nuova vita intorno a sé
che mette a frutto le proprie competenze
i propri talenti
per gli altri e genera relazioni
autentiche
ecco la felicità che cercavo essere
fecondo per la vita degli altri
la felicità
affinare i propri talenti fino a farli
maturare mettere a disposizione di altre
persone quand'anche dovesse costarci
sacrificio tempo e energie felicità è
mettere al mondo un figlio diventare
maestri educatori amici quando anche
dovesse significare mettere fra
parentesi i propri interessi propri
progetti felicità è dare la vita per
qualcosa per qualcuno quand'anche
dovesse significare perdere la pazienza
o il sonno o la vita stessa
certo non è la felicità frizzante che ci
propongono le pubblicità quella che si
stappa fa le bollicine e poi finisce e
lasciandoci peggio di prima
questa è una felicità reale che perdura
nel tempo che corrisponde alla verità
della lastra dita e la verità sulla
nostra vita e che noi non possiamo
concepirci solo come individui ma
innanzitutto come persone un individuo
si definisce sono a partire da sé
inizia con se stesso e finisce con se
stesso una persona invece si definisce a
partire dalle sue relazioni noi siamo le
nostre relazioni
nel bene e nel male siamo i nostri
genitori siamo i nostri amici siamo le
persone che ci hanno aiutato e purtroppo
oppure quelle che sono ferito se io
voglio essere felice innanzitutto io
devo essere io e io chi sono io non sono
solo un individuo ma innanzitutto una
persona quindi la mia felicità è legata
agli altri ci hanno sempre insegnato che
chi fa da sé fa per tre
che meglio soli che male accompagnati
che la tua libertà finisce dove inizia
la mia sono fatto credere che l'io viene
prima del tour e che quindi i miei
diritti vengono sempre prima dei tuoi ci
hanno portato pensare che stiamo bene
solo se ci concentriamo su noi stessi e
che gli altri valgono se ne importanti
nella misura in cui sono utili per noi è
tutto questo è vero nella bisogno in cui
vogliamo accontentarci di una vita
comoda ma se vogliamo una vita felice
cioè seconda una vita piena
senso ricordiamoci chi siamo siamo
persone
siamo le nostre relazioni
siamo fatti per amare e questo il nostro
cuore lo sa come quando arriva la
felicità grazie
[Applauso]